i'm going to show you today maybe the
silliest and dumbest and least
believable explanation
for why there was a raid a search
warrant executed at donald trump's
mar-a-lago
we've heard everything we've heard it
was done
because of hunter biden's laptop we've
heard it was done because joe biden is
trying to get political retribution we
heard that the fbi planted evidence we
heard all these different things on and
on and on and of course it's all been
made up the real reason that there was a
raid at mar-a-lago
is because the fbi
and the justice department
as sean hannity says
crossed all of their eyes and dotted all
of their t's that his words not mine
um and it was approved by merrick
garland the attorney general and by the
fbi director and by a judge because
there was evidence
that donald trump had things at his
house that he wasn't supposed to have
that's the real reason
that the raid happened
however
listen to what joni ernst says
republican senator is the real reason
and the timing of this when we have
40-year high inflation when we have the
highest gas prices that americans have
seen during this administration when we
have an open southern border with all of
the crises that have happened during
this administration they needed a little
bit of a distraction and this was prime
opportunity for this administration to
pounce on president trump make it about
this raid rather than about the only
problems they have manufactured in the
last two years what doesn't make any
sense about that i'm going to tell you
in a moment
real quick first let me tell you about
our sponsor aura
imagine this scenario you try logging
into your email account to see that your
password was changed a few hours ago
except you didn't do it and then you get
notifications of activity from your bank
and from your credit cards but you
didn't do any of it that is what
identity theft is like it can happen
very quickly and if you don't act fast
it can get worse we've dealt with this
at the david pakman show you can find
videos about it and that's why i protect
myself now using aura our sponsor aura
is identity theft protection fraud
monitoring password management and an
antivirus all in one easy to use app
aura will monitor the dark web for your
emails passwords and social security
numbers and will send you alerts quickly
to your phone and email aura also gives
you near real-time alerts on suspicious
credit inquiries like if someone was
opening a loan or a credit card in your
name and if you sign up at aura.com
pacman you will get a free two-week
trial which you can use to see if your
login credentials have been leaked
online
i would want to know that right away use
the link below
okay so joni ernst says the mar-a-lago
raid was meant to distract from the high
gas prices the only problem with that is
that the mar-a-lago raid took place on
august 8th and if you look at this chart
i have up on the screen and look at what
was happening on august 8th gas prices
were getting to
we don't i can't say the end but gas
prices were getting
very much into a dramatically fast
decline dramatically fast decline one of
the fastest declines to gas prices that
we have ever seen in the united states
why on earth would democrats merit
garland whoever say hey you know what
gas prices are coming down so fast and
that's great for joe biden and great for
us even if it doesn't have anything to
do with biden as i've said before
let's distract from the great news of
gas prices coming down
by executing a search warrant at
mar-a-lago
what
do you think joni ernst even believes
this or is she just saying it but knows
that it's worth nothing more than the
stuff trump flushes down his toilet 10
to 15 times
let me know in the comments